the financial independence path really
is freeing up your life from debt and
from the obsessive desire you know
obsessive materialism I was leading a
session on our relationship with money I
just was curious about where people were
with this at this point this was in 2016
we had 50 people in the room we circled
up and we went around our room just say
something about your relationship with
money and I really every person in that
room was in fear about money from the 80
year old who I know has millions of
dollars and to the 20 year old who was
like already $20,000 in debt and it was
it just honestly it infuriated me like
what kind of society requires that
everybody participate in something that
terrifies them this this feels so a
missed me and then I started to talk to
the 20 year old several 20 year olds in
the room about their dad and I realized
that they were had bought into a story
that don't worry about the debt you
accumulate because you'll be able to pay
it off through your profession that a
college education
if so facto produces X percent more
income over a lifetime but that they
were training in professions that may
actually disappear by the time they're
fully trained and and I thought what
kind of society turns its financial
system on its young people and you know
I was like sort of lurid so I said you
know harvests the organs of the young I
just felt like I was looking and
watching like this old vultures of the
financial system having discovered one
more profit Center and it was it was
their children so there's a certain
level at which we really need to pay
attention to the politics of this whole
situation for example one of the one of
the big barriers to the people in this
movement actually pulling the trigger
and becoming financially independent is
that their health care is tied to their
job so I believe that is a social good
that we all have to work on we need to
work on some
of medicare-for-all and in a way it's a
rising tide it's going to happen there's
no question about it
it's just how it happens and when it
happens and what are the mechanisms for
it but we really need to support that
because not everybody is in a corporate
setting where they can get health care
that's a big personal expense you know
or college debt you know eventually I
believe our society will need to go
toward something that is K through 16
education for everybody so that we are
not graduating our young people with
that degree of debt because that puts
them in a financially not independent
state for the rest of their lives we
really eventually need to think about
how the rule how the game is designed
and to make it easier for more people I
call it fi for all financial
independence for everybody how can
everybody be free of the fear that I saw
in that room two years ago that got me
to do the update of your money your life
that everybody in that room was afraid
for their financial future everybody
felt stuck that's not an appropriate way
to run a country
[Music]